Suicide Squad is finally here, bringing us
the worst bunch of heroes to ever hit the
silver screen.
Now it's time to discuss what the ending of
the film means for DC’s movie franchise.
That is, if it can survive the rough reviews
and actually still get a sequel.
Spoilers ahead!.
New Squad
In the final act, our heroic band of villains
spared the world from destruction, and one
didn’t make it out alive.
Even after the Squad saved the day, Amanda
Waller only took 10 years off their sentences,
so it was back to prison for the crew.
Thankfully, the Squad has a history of revolving
members, so we could definitely see some new
blood in a sequel.
The team's included the likes of Killer Frost,
Parasite, Doctor Light, and even The Penguin.
With El Diablo dead and Harley Quinn freed
by the Joker, there are some slots to fill.
Here's hoping for a gigantic CGI King Shark.
Harley Quinn's Misadventures
Beyond potentially appearing in a Suicide
Squad sequel, Harley Quinn will reportedly
be getting her own movie, so expect to see
the mallet-wielding psycho return.
Even though the Joker busted her out of prison
at the end of Suicide Squad, we're hoping
Harley can spread her wings without being
tethered to the Clown Prince of Crime.
Her spinoff could include the return of Katana...or
maybe her longtime partner in crime, Poison
Ivy, perhaps?
Waller’s End
Amanda Waller is a character who quickly asserts
herself as a force to be reckoned with.
As a master manipulator, she does what's necessary
to serve her own agenda, including killing
innocents to protect her interests.
She's threatened every member of the Suicide
Squad, including Rick Flagg.
In the animated film Assault on Arkham, Deadshot
makes sure that Waller knows that he has the
upper hand.
There's no love lost between these two, so
it's possible that we could see that story
advance in a Suicide Squad sequel.
Justice
If you stuck around long enough to watch the
mid-credits scene, you were treated to a faceoff
between Waller and Bruce Wayne.
Waller wanted protection from the media and
gave Wayne some dossiers of metahumans in
return.
The two had a tense exchange toward the end
of the scene, with Waller implying that she
knows Bruce Wayne is Batman.
If there's one thing Waller is good at, it's
getting leverage.
What would happen if the Justice League had
shut down Task Force X?
Deadshot And Harley forever
In the comics, Deadshot and Harley Quinn enjoyed
a turbulent and short-lived romance.
Meanwhile, the chemistry between Will Smith
and Margot Robbie is hard to miss, and a relationship
could potentially be explored in a sequel.
After all, Deadshot purposely missed his shot
at Harley, giving up the chance to see his
daughter.
If that doesn't scream "I like you!" then
nothing does.
The Return Of Katana
Katana was on hand to help Rick Flagg keep
the villains in line, but we only saw a little
bit of her backstory and soul-stealing sword.
She's rumored to return in Harley's spinoff
film, but whether she comes back as friend
or foe is up in the air.
We'd like to think she'd be sent by Waller
to bring Quinn back to prison, but we'd also
love to see a Katana and Harley team-up.
“She seems nice.”
Thanks for watching!
Subscribe to our YouTube channel to watch
more videos like the one you just saw.
And leave us a comment to let us know what
you think could happen in the Suicide Squad’s
future…